[Music]
ursula k le guin's now classic short
essay from elf elfland to poughkeepsie
has a number of important themes and
argued judgments built into it
interconnecting with each other and
we're going to try to disentangle them a
bit so we can better understand exactly
what is being put forth in this essay
which is a piece of literary criticism
it's also kind of self-referential
her
various worlds could fit into what we're
going to call elf land so we should
start with that what is
alphaland and that's where she begins
the essay saying elfland is what lord
dunze called the place it is also known
as middle earth and prydane and the
forest of broccoli on and once upon a
time and by many other
names so this is not restricting it just
to
those paradigmatic
texts and narrative universes
you don't actually have to have elves
you don't necessarily have to have she's
going to talk about dragons later on but
there are some defining traits of
what she's calling elfland that she's
going to contrast to poughkeepsie and
before we go into that we should say
well what's what's poughkeepsie if
you're not familiar
with the united states you might not
know what she's referencing by
poughkeepsie i actually used to teach in
pickpsi at marist college and uh you
know it's not the poughkeepsie of her
day in 1973 but it is you know largely
the the same kind of place it's a very
prosaic spot there's not a lot of
fantasy going on there although there
might be people playing d and d in their
homes or watching the lord of the rings
on on you know blu-ray or something like
that or in the theater but poughkeepsie
is supposed to be sort of you know an
average
american place she actually speculates
at one point what would be the british
equivalent of poughkeepsie and we could
say this about pretty much any country
it's it's a place where there might be
the trappings of fantasy but there isn't
really
fantasy and she's going to use it she's
going to talk about the poughkeepsie
style or approach
so elfland as she's going to point out
towards the end of the essay
is actually a secondary she's going to
call it universe tolkien's word was
secondary
world
and um
here we go
she says in fantasy there's nothing but
the writer's vision of the world there
is no borrowed reality of history or
current events or just plain folks at
home in peyton place there is no
comfortable matrix of the commonplace to
substitute for the imagination to
provide ready-made emotional response
and to disguise flaws and failures of
creation there is only a construct built
in a void with every joint and seam and
nail exposed to create what tolkien
calls a
secondary
universe or tolkien actually said
secondary world or sub-creation
is to make a new world a world where no
voice has ever spoken before where the
act of speech is the act of creation the
only voice that speaks there is the
creator's voice and every word
counts so genuine fantasy is in some
respects although it is drawing on you
know previous things as we're going to
talk about and measuring itself against
prime examples of its genre
it's
doing something a bit different it's not
just transposing
what we currently have
into you know wearing armor and facing
dragons or something like that that
makes for bad fantasy or perhaps not
fantasy at all and she goes on and asks
the question well what is
fantasy itself and she says this is
important because fantasy right now is
selling well
so she says what is fantasy this is very
early on
on one level it's a game a pure pretense
with no ulterior motive whatsoever it's
one child saying to another child let's
be dragons and then they're dragons for
an hour or two it's escapism of the most
admirable kind the game played for the
game's sake and escapism
is in fact part of fantasy but can that
be all that there really is to it she
says no
she says on another level
it's still a game
but a game played for very high stakes
seen thus as art not spontaneous play
its affinity is not with daydream
but with dream it's a different approach
to reality an alternative technique for
apprehending and coping with existence
it is not anti-rational
but para rational anti-rational would be
against reason pararational is alongside
reason right supplementing not realistic
but surrealistic super realistic a
heightening
of reality then she says in freud's
terminology it employs primary not
secondary process thinking it employs
archetypes which as jung warned us are
dangerous things fantasy is nearer to
poetry to mysticism and to insanity the
naturalistic fiction is it is a real
wilderness and those here's a key idea
those who go there
should not feel too safe and their
guides the writers of fantasy should
take their responsibilities seriously so
this is something that she thinks is
there in all genuine fantasy later on
she'll also talk about epic poetry like
that of beowulf or the iliad and that is
in many respects akin to fantasy
as well so fantasy bears it well it's
not the same thing as that it bears
similarities to that
she also says that in fantasy style
it has a
fundamental significance as we're going
to
see and and this is really the linchpin
of the essay the thing around which all
the other distinctions can be argued to
turn
particularly that of
poughkeepsie fantasy which is not really
fantasy at all
there's been she thinks a
commercialization that is taking place
and she's got this wonderful metaphor at
the beginning of national park she says
what happens when elf land
is considered merely as a place to get
away to when it becomes you know a
consumer product some fantasy so that we
can watch game of thrones and chit chat
about it at our party
you know the ill-fated game of thrones
of course because the writers ruined it
in part because they didn't understand
fantasy they also didn't understand
george r martin's story as well
and you know there's a lot more that can
be said about that but you know you
could also think of the churn of fantasy
novels many of which are not
particularly good and leguin is
observing this so she says what happens
when when elfland becomes a place merely
to get away with to you know what's
happened to yosemite everyone comes not
with an axe and a book of matches but in
a trailer with a motorbike on the back
and a motorboat on top and a butane
stove five aluminum folding chairs and a
transistor radio on the inside it'd be
even worse now right glamping is a prime
example of not really camping you know
they go from park to park but they never
really go anywhere
except when one of them who thinks that
even the wildlife isn't real gets chewed
up by a genuine first-hand bear or has
happened more recently stupid tourists
getting burned in very hot water coming
from you know hot springs and geysers
right
so fantasy
isn't just a nice safe consumer product
she also talks about a journalization
of fantasy
towards the very end of it and i think
this is on point as well
she talks about
here we go
the poughkeepsie style of fantasy is
written in a plain and apparently direct
prose does that make it equal to
tolkien's alas no it's a fake plainness
it's not really simple
but flat notice that distinction it's
not simple prose it's flat prose it's
not really clear
but inexact
its directness is species
its sensory cues are vague and
generalized the rocks the wind the trees
are not there are not felt the scenery
is cardboard or plastic the tone as a
whole is profoundly inappropriate to the
subject to what then is it appropriate
to journalism
it is journalistic prose in journalism
the suppression of the author's
personality and sensibility is
deliberate the goal is an impression
notice the word there an impression of
objectivity the whole thing is meant to
be written fast and read faster
this technique is right she says for a
newspaper it is wrong for a novel and
dead wrong for fantasy so this actually
leads us to
one of the
ways in which she talks about this
poughkeepsie style there's really two
sides to it so one side is this
false objectivity
this flatness this seeming plainness
plain and apparently direct prose she
says
it just happens to have fantasy content
and a great example of this is provided
by one of her objects that she uses at
the beginning
will read both of these things right
so
here's a little excerpt
from a book the person's talking are
duke of the royal the blood royal of a
mythical celtical kingdom
celtic kingdom and a warrior magician
whether or not they succeed in the end
will depend largely on kelson's personal
ability to manipulate the voting can he
morgan asked as the two clattered down a
half flight of stairs and into the
garden i don't know alaric nigel replied
he's good damned good but i just don't
know besides you saw the key council
lords with ralston dead and bran chorus
practically making open accusations well
it doesn't look good i could have told
you that at cardosa
and leguin goes on and says you could
take this exact prose
and set it in washington dc
right
so the two clatter down a half flight of
stairs into the white house garden
and they talk about key committee
chairman instead of the key council
lords and her point is she says
something has gone wrong the book from
which i quoted is not fantasy
for all its equipment of heroes and
wizards if it was fantasy i couldn't
have pulled that dirty trick on it by
changing four words
and suddenly transposing it the content
doesn't make it fantasy right so
that's a good example of this there's
also a long discussion of what she calls
mistakenly distancing from the ordinary
in one style and she runs through a
non-exhaustive list of ways in which
writers screw up
she she goes on and says you know style
is is problematic
here we go
[Applause]
she she says that one of the ways that
people
make this mistake is
they see this distancing done
beautifully in old works like mallory's
mort darter and in new books the style
of which is grounded on the old books
and they think aha i'll do it too
then she says but elay acid is one of
those things like bison bicycling and
computer programming that you have got
to know how to do it before you do it
so our novice says you have to use verbs
with v and thou so they do but they
don't actually know how to do that
because we don't use the and thou
anymore then our novice tries to use the
subjunctive and english writers are not
you know
particularly good at using that because
we don't use it an awful lot consciously
we certainly don't teach it anymore
right all the wuzzes turn into words and
leap out at the reader snarling
then she goes down further and she says
we aren't through yet
we haven't had the fancy words eldritch
tenebrous smarrogs and chalcedony mayhap
it can't be maybe it can't be perhaps it
has to be mayhap unless it's perchance
and then comes the final test the
infallible touchstone of the seventh
rate
icker you know ickhart oozes out a
severed tentacles and the slimes
tessellated pavements and the spatters
bejeweled courtiers and bores the
bejesus out of everybody the archaic
manner she says is indeed a perfect
distancer but you have to do it
perfectly it's a high wire one slip
spoils all so archaisms are not actually
going to cut it in style and she goes on
you know with some some other examples
as well
you know making things
more complicated than they need to be
and so these are the poughkeepsie the
two sides you could say of the
poughkeepsie approach to writing fantasy
short stories and novels either doing
plain and apparently direct prose that
you just insert some fantasy content
into or trying to talk like a fantasy
person right fantasy we could call it
lingo
but not style
she also discusses some authors in a bit
of a digression
who have what she's thinking of as mixed
styles where they their their work is
heroic and comic at the same time and
when it's heroic they speak in a heroic
way but when it's comic they talk in the
ordinary parlance of you know whatever
time period they're writing uh
you know rogers zelazny here we're
thinking perhaps of the chronicles of
amber
for its liber we could think of the
fawford and the grey mouser stuff as
well as many others she also mentions
jack vance but she says vance doesn't do
quite the same
thing as them and she says fritz liber
and rogers of the lassie lazy both
written in the comic heroic vein
their technique is to alternate when
humor is intended they speak colloquial
american english or even slaying right
readers indifferent to language do not
mind this but for others the strain is
too great i am one of those latter so
it's interesting to see her you know
zelazny and leguin are part of the same
time and and movements often called the
new wave of you know science fiction and
fantasy and here she's she's criticizing
zelazny for that she says it's strange
because
both libra and zelazny are skillful and
highly imaginative writers and it's
perfectly clear that libra
profoundly acquainted with shakespeare
in practice in a very broad range of
techniques could maintain any tone with
eloquence and grace
sometimes i wonder if these two
underestimate their own talents or they
lack confidence in themselves or it may
be that since fantasy is seldom taken
seriously at this particular era they
are afraid to take it seriously
themselves and so their humor becomes
self-mocking and self-destructive their
gods and heroes keep turning aside to
look out of the book at you and whisper
see we're just really plain folks
and she goes on and talks about vance he
says his humor is so quiet you can miss
it if you blink the whole tone of his
writing is so modest sometimes i wonder
whether he fails to realize how good of
a writer he is
if so it's probably a result of the
patronizing attitude american culture
effects towards works of pure
imagination but vance never compromises
with the patronizing and ignorant he
never lets his creation down in order to
make a joke and he never shows a tin ear
for tone the conversation of his
characters is aloof and restrained very
like his own narrative prose an unusual
kind of english it is an achieved style
and it contains
narcasms at all
this leads us to talking about style
a little bit earlier on in the work she
talks about the lords of elflam and
she does so in the context of bringing
up something that is already there
discussed in aristotle's
poetics which is about tragedy right and
the great tragedians like sophocles or
echelos or euripides already knew
speech
expresses
character not all speech does but the
speech of the characters is how they
convey what aristotle called the annoy a
thought and ethos character right
it does so whether the speaker or author
does so
or not when i hear a man say i could
have told you that at cardoso or at
poughkeepsie or wherever i think i know
something about that man he's the kind
who says i told you so nobody says
nobody who says i told you so has ever
been or will be a hero
the lords of elfland she says are true
lords the only true lords the kind that
do not exist on this earth their
lordship is the outward sign or symbol
of real
inward greatness and greatness of soul
shows when a person speaks at least it
does in books in life we expect lapses
in naturalistic fiction we expect
lapses and laugh at an over heroic hero
but in fantasy which instead of
imitating the perceived confusion and
complexity of existence tries to hint
this is a wonderful phrase at an order
and clarity underlying existence in
fantasy we need no compromise every word
spoken is meaningful though the meaning
may be
subtle so this is you know a very
important and robust expression here
she also tells us that
if we're going to write fantasy
or if we're going to measure fantasy we
should measure it not against the
average
the mediocre but against the best
and she says that
it might seem unfair for me to pick the
best like edison morris and tolkien in
talking about style but i don't think
it's unfair in art the best is the
standard
when you hear a new violinist you don't
compare her to the kid next door you
compare her to stern and high fets if
she falls short you won't blame her for
it but you will know what she falls
short of and if she's a real violinist
she knows it too in art
good enough is not good enough
isn't that a great
discussion and exemplification of how we
should understand this
later on she talks about the mistake of
thinking that style is something you
could just kind of like put on or to use
the other metaphor season things with it
doesn't work that way she she says and
this is a fundamental mistake that leads
people into the poughkeepsie
way of looking at things
here we go
many readers
many critics
most editors speak of style as if it
were an ingredient of a book like the
sugar in a cake
or something added onto the book like
the frosting on the cake
you can have a cake without sugar right
it's not going to be very sweet but it's
still a cake you can have a cake without
frosting definitely the the frosting is
in many respects unless it's a certain
kind of cake unnecessary
the style she says is of course the book
if you remove the cake all you have left
is a recipe
if you remove the style
all you have left is a synopsis of the
plot this is partly true of history she
says only partly true
largely true of fiction
only largely true
and absolutely true of fantasy
and she says we can look at this two
ways
in saying the style of the book i speak
from the reader's point of view from the
writer's point of view the style is the
writer style isn't just how you use
english when you write it's not a
mannerism or affectation it's not
something you can do without
it you can't do without it there is no
is without it it's it provides you could
say
the being
the fabric of what is being
written what is being articulated it is
how you see your vision your
understanding of the world your
voice and she says listen you can learn
style you can imitate style all of
that's possible
but there has to be style and that's
what's lacking or
defective in the poughkeepsie approach
and that's what the mixed style is
confused about in her view
we should end by talking about the role
of plain language now not everybody that
she mentions with great style is using
plain language some of them are using
archaic language but they walk the
tightrope
well
they manage to pull it off because of
their style which probably cannot be
adequately imitated except by other
great
stylists themselves
but tolkien provides an example here of
a very straightforward and plain
language as she says
so a little bit earlier tolkien writes a
a plain clear english its outstanding
virtue is its flexibility its variety it
ranges easily from the commonplace to
the stately and can slide into metrical
poetry as in the tom bombadil episode
without the careless readers even
noticing tolkien's vocabulary is not
striking he has no icor everything is
direct concrete and simple and so that
is certainly one way to do it here we
also see a resemblance to epic poetry
right she says did henry v of england
really talk like shakespeare's henry did
the real achilles use hexameters would
the real beowulf please stand up and
alliterate we're not discussing history
but heroic fantasy we're discussing a
modern descendant of the epic most epics
are in straightforward language whether
prose or verse homer's metaphors may be
extended but they are neither static nor
ornate the song of roland has four
thousand lines containing one simile and
no
metaphors the
mabinogian and the norse sagas are as
plain spoken as could well be clarity
and simplicity are permanent virtues in
a narrative a plain language
is the noblest of all so if we're going
to depart from plain language it has to
come organically it has to fit it cannot
be something put on for the marketplace
right or to imitate and thereby win
ourselves a place in the fantasy
pantheon because fantasy is one of those
things where
true greatness winds up being recognized
by people and mediocrity also winds up
being recognized despite the number of
book sales by
looking where people keep going back
right we keep still reading
tolkien
and leguin
and vance
and some of these other authors as well
so a lot of important themes running
through elf land to poughkeepsie there's
nothing wrong with with poughkeepsie
she's not saying get rid of it
but elfland has to
stand on its own in literary works
and we don't want poughkeepsie
becoming the model
for
elfland or elfland ceases to be
what it is
you